michael moore puce découvre celui que tu
devrais être le méchant
[Musique]
michael qu'est ce que tu as fait je
voulais aider les gens
mais leurs remèdes
et pire que le mal we can
je possède des pouvoirs qu'on peut
qualifier de surhumain
et ce à un prix
non je suis face à un dilemme chasser
et consommer du sang
ou mourir nous avons tous un monstre qui
sommeille en nous
il nous appartient de le contrôler
et si je n'y arrive pas
michael morbius
tu as reçu un taux pas exactement
je devrai oublier celui que tu étais et
découvrir celui que tu devrais être
notre vie on a vécu sous le couperet de
la mort pourquoi il ne se mettraient pas
notre place pour changer
accepte d'être celui que tu es désormais
le méchant
vous êtes loin d'être le gringalet qu'on
voit aux infos oui vous avez l'air
solide comme un roc merci le pilates